and even like five or six years ago
don't use today's
rules and and beliefs to blame people
for things they said on the internet
eight years ago like we thank you for
screaming the n-word
ten years ago it was fine a lot yeah it
was comedy i mean
george carlin andrew dice clay these
guys would be
their families would be canceled if we
held them to the today's
i don't know how the young turks still
exist the name of their program is
effectively the hitler youth dude i was
just reading about the
genocide and the young ones the ottoman
empire had this
group called the young turks that
basically took all these uh armenians
and marched them
south and millions uh 1.6 million
armenians died in this and they still to
this day say
that wasn't a genocide if if there's any
like good example of
grifting i think it's definitely the
young turks glenn greenwald
jimmy dore aaron mate that have there's
been this big feud going on between the
young turks and them
and genter comes out and tweets it's the
alt left
and they made these false out of context
accusations which then the alt-right
started saying and i'm just like bro
the the alt left it was a nebulous term
from a few years ago people tried to
work and no one really uses it
and the alt-right has literally nothing
to do with why people don't like you
jank yeuger accused aaron mate of being
paid by the russians
and uh anna casparian said something
like he seems to be working for
dictators
it was a smear because they didn't like
that he was
the the journalism he does it sparked
this huge feud
i gotta say you look back at the history
of the young turks the things jenk yuger
has said
about women he got cancelled from the
justice democrats over it
the videos of him talking about women
and their their junk
and insulting like this the things he
said i actually don't care
he's allowed to have his opinions and
oftentimes he was joking but he's
dropped racial slurs repeatedly
the name of their show is effectively
the hitler youth
yet they just don't care they don't care
so when he comes out and he's like
these are unfounded accusations against
us i'm like bro you're you literally
work for a company that's like
like effectively praising genocide you
know like you've named yourself
after a group that committed a genocide
uh you know i don't think you're serious
when you're talking about reform
and how people change because you didn't
well i don't know i mean he has and i
don't hear him screaming the n-word
anymore but
anyway my original point i guess is just
don't we're not i'm not
whatever people said crazy stuff in the
past let it go today is today it's a
different this is a different political
development this is my point
here's a guy who won't change the name
of his company
and he could he could here's a guy who
went on
the old and defended child stripping
he did oh of course they'll call it
something else i don't care what they
call it the fact is
there's a little kid who was at a club
full of adults taking his clothes off
and they're throwing money out
he wasn't he still had he still had uh
like undergarments on
but as a little boy and they did a whole
segment defending it probably more than
one jordan klepper of comedy central did
that as well
and i'm like at a certain point you
realize what these people do
they're not progressive they're just
what
their path of least resistance when the
media says you're allowed to make these
jokes it's edgy and it's fun
oh they go on they say every racial slur
in the book they make fun of women
they show that they were talking about
like you know um
bottom shots of women climbing out of
cars that's one thing they're getting
heat for
nowadays they're like we won't do that
because we're principled and we oppose
misogyny no you don't
you're literally just saying lowest
common denominator left talking points
to fit in they're completely opinions
didn't change no no no they're not
jimmy dore he's a comedian yeah they're
not
i'll tell you this when i have a video
from six seven years ago where i'm like
segregated graduations are a bad thing
and today i'm like segregated
graduations are a bad thing
you hypocrite you have the same position
right using a different definition for
the word segment
now hold on i have positions that have
changed i used to be like
gun control maybe now i'm like no gun
control boom free guns for children and
things like that
that's that's not a path of least
resistance for anybody the popular
mainstream narrative
is to be for gun control if anything
i've become more contrarian
in opposition they've become more
establishment
say whatever needs to be said we'll just
say whatever you don't want no opinion i
want to ask chank about
2016 when hillary's emails came out and
it showed that they were like pushing
bernie sanders out of the race
because that was when i saw chang like
something snapped in his brain
and he became almost sociopathic like
having a hard time
accepting the d i mean i know he knows
that there's corruption in dnc but i
want to just go deep on his brain
i'll i'll give him some credit he he
recently did an interview with the hill
where he said the democratic
establishment just lies all the time
he's completely correct about that i
just think his whole bit is
stay where it's safe all the time and so
he's like we're
we're changing our opinions for
principles like no you're not you're
just staying in the safe you're staying
in the safest possible place you can
when edginess was fun you were in it now
it put pc
you're in it do something counter for
once that's interesting uh
perspective on the overton window for
them yeah
the overton window for them has moved
dramatically to now where even
these guys that are leftists who used to
make
jokes all the time about language and be
what we would consider
non-politically correct today now the
overton window has shifted so
far that they have to disavow like their
entire back catalog
and just adopt a whole new system of
language and thought in order to stay
acceptable that's what you get when
you're trying to stay inside the overton
window you know what's more fun
pushing the overton window in different
directions that's more fun
i love it uh i'll i'll absolutely stand
up
for myself and my principles i
criticized andy no over him going on on
the ground
into into the fray with antifa long
story short
they you know i i expressed my views and
i got a lot of flack for it
and i got called a grifter with no
principles for
for what was i was i trying to build a
leftist audience
these people hate me no it's because i'm
standing up for what i believe in even
if it's unpopular
even if it's a threat to to my mic even
if there are people who follow me like
i'm gonna unfollow you i'm like
look man i can only tell you how i feel
i made i made a tweet about anonymity
and people took it out of context that
was funny and i'm just going to say what
i think dude and if you don't want to
hear it i'm sorry like you don't have to
you're not somewhere else
i appreciate you guys watching if you
did but if you want to watch someone
who's going to say tribalist opinions go
watch the young turks
it's funny people i do the same thing
and people will accuse me of punching
right
or uh or being a grifter or being
controlled opposition
yeah i've controlled opposition i i love
it when i get that one because basically
it just means somebody on the far right
doesn't like the fact that i'm boxing
them out and saying no we don't really
want you
over here you're hurting us this big
tent does not include you
okay and then they call me controlled
opposition which is hilarious like
how am i being controlled what are they
giving me are they giving me access and
prestige
can i have my blue check please i got
denied are they giving me money and
support and resources
no are they giving me distribution no
are they shadow banning me yes are they
signing my
my shares and all that yes how am i
controlled opposition
it's a non-thing you're the trojan horse
that's what i think of myself
you're contr you've allowed yourself to
become what seems like
you know safe but then when they let you
into the city that you
they realize you were there to i mean
that i kind of changed like that's what
i'm trying to do now i've reached such a
bigger audience a more mainstream
audience
that i can drop like red pill stuff from
10 10 years ago
and it's like just old hat stuff that we
talked got so tired of even talking
about
that now i'm in an audience now where
it's like fresh news to people oh yeah
it's fascinating actually it's like oh
my life's very easy i just have to
remember
what we were talking about 2010 and now
the mainstream is actually ready for
that in 2021
because all the things that we said were
happening at that time back in 2010 all
the crazy
feminist conspiracies and all that it's
all come true
i got i got something to say to the
young turks you know
jenks he called jimmy doremonster let's
fight that's what he's
so so i i saw jenkuger at uh politicon
couple years ago
and they had published they did a video
about this
fake bit of research claiming that there
was it's called the alternative
influencer network they put my name
right in the middle
it was the most ridiculous bs they
claimed that i had done interviews with
people i'd never met before
they claimed that i did a youtube video
with stefan molyneux never met the guy
and so when they did a video and they
show the screenshot my name's in the
middle
i saw jenk standing in a hallway and i
was like hey you got a second and he's
like oh hold on i'm busy
and he was talking to someone and after
that i was like i just wanted to mention
like you guys
i dm'd you about this because i saw i'd
seen him at vidcon before and we were
talking and shaking his hand i told him
that like
i bought ads on his channel before on
youtube was like stifling them
and so i was like hey you guys did this
video about the the alternative
influencer network or something that
included me like i don't i don't know
what your beef is with dave rubin or
anything i just don't want to be
involved
and he was like i don't know i don't
know what you're talking about and i was
like dude i'm trying to ask you to like
not include me in it and then all of a
sudden
he snapped started screaming at me what
happened to you man
you have changed well he's yelling at me
on all this everyone starts filming and
i'm like why are you yelling at me
i didn't say anything mean to you ever
at all in fact i was i was being
respectful to him on youtube as well
dude snap claimed i changed so i got a
message
if dave rubin jimmy dore tim poole glenn
greenwald michael tracy airmate are all
changing around you maybe it's you who
need to check your boots
maybe you're started by sycophants who
are just blowing smoke up your ass
and telling you what you want to hear
and the people who leave your presence
all of a sudden are like yo
you're nuts jimmy dore leaves the young
turks and all of a sudden he's like
here's what's happening
and chang's like why did he change and
dave rubin leaves the young turks
why did dave change i was never anything
to do with young turks but all of a
sudden
jenkins shocked timpool changed glenn
greenwald what happened to you
no no no nothing happened to us
something happened to you
look at your old videos we we're no
you're just saying what is safe for the
establishment
and i think that's true of ethan klein
as well dude used to be edgy
now he's safe they're too scared to risk
anything
to stand up for anything you don't have
to that's fine by me
you want to protect your network and you
want to be you want to be some kind of
progressive
you know channel and just say whatever
the tribe wants you to say
fine that's fine but stop acting shocked
when everyone else who leaves your
presence starts saying things that shock
you
because it may just be that you're
surrounded by yes men and still are
yeah you know it's a much easier brand
image to maintain
one of seeking knowledge or truth
oh that's the brand oh which means i'm
going to change
and evolve that's all part of the plan
we're on a journey we're trying to
discover the truth we're trying to learn
what's really happening we're trying to
create
a mental model of the world that makes
it so we're not insane
that's much easier than to say i'm an
ideologue on this idea and i can't
change
they box themselves i'm not i'm not
trying to make them
seem any better than they are but
they're boxed in and
anybody on the right it's the same way
totally boxed in if you haven't set
yourself up in a way that you're just
going to evolve
which is what humans do which is a
totally natural thing to do
yes i have more information on that
matter so my opinion has changed
that's great my opinion changed quite a
bit you know talking to michael malus
and people like libertarians are
tweeting and i'm like you you got tim
good job
because i was like abolish the police
bro i'm like watching cops confiscate
guns from law-abiding citizens to uphold
you i'm watching these ridiculous laws
i'm watching the capital police
dude you're the one that they were
referencing when they said that the
right
was claiming that they needed to fund
the police remember that
when the press secretary gets up there
and she's like it's been the republicans
and the conservatives trying to defund
the
here's my point capitol police capitol
police
dc capital police are setting up field
offices in california and florida
they're expanding nationwide the capitol
police issued a press release saying
they're going to be expanding into an
intelligence-based protective agency
yeah because the war on terror is coming
home so my stance has been
not the same as the left that their evil
oppressors and shut them down it's that
now the good cops are leaving
and the cops who are staying are are a
lot of them are dirty no the good cops
yase fueron spanish they already left
right they're gone so let's not sit back
and be like defend the institution i'm
like
nah because now you're going to get
capital police hunting down
quote unquote patriots here's here's my
prediction i could be wrong about this
but i'll give you a prediction oh thank
god i didn't go that day
capital police yeah capitol police are
investigating
and the feds are tracking down the
people who went in the building the
capital police are setting up field
offices
do you think this will stop or do you
think that once they get the 600 people
they're going to say now we're going to
go after those who provided material to
support to these people no dude we have
a very
extreme hardcore concrete bulletproof
uh example of the way the government
once they set up these kind of things
they shut them down in due time right
look at this thing in cuba it's
guantanamo bay
they set it up right after 9 11 they put
prisoners in there they closed it down
as soon as they were done
and then that was it wait what what oh
no it's still open wait i'm sorry
wait what was that wait they didn't
close down it's squadron is still open
i remember honestly i remember when uh i
was in new york when they announced that
they got osama and uh obama came out and
he was like the war on pair
was over and i was like wow they just
ended it
hey oh wait that didn't happen either no
so here's my
wait did he really say that no oh
so i was like they didn't assassinate
him the next day so
so here's what i'm saying the capitol
police they're going to go after the
rioters
then they're going to say the people
providing material support then they're
going to say
we need to expand more offices to stop
to be preemptive
to prevent these things from happening
ever again the war on terror comes home
right and then when they actually talk
to a guy like omar mateen
and they know that he wants to go around
killing people they're just going to let
him go
because that's actually not what they're
really after what'd that guy do i shot
up the uh the orlando nightclub
which wasn't actually a gay motivated
thing he was just like
nearest nightclub and it turned out to
be that one full of gay people and so it
became like a gay massacre when really
it wasn't
yeah he was a tragedy he was he was a he
was a a
like a um a person of interest or
whatever a technical term probably not
used that right
to the fbi they knew him in advance
he scoped out that nightclub he murdered
the people in there and then they
retrofitted it to be like a gay
i remember who it was um but someone
said that
uh they they said the united states
needed some kind of 9 11 like attack
in their opinion as a republican to
remind people
why we have the security state wait wait
they said this after 9 11 yeah
they were like it's almost like we just
need it to happen so that people
remember exactly what you know we're
fighting for whatever
something like that i mean look it's
funny like we we've been on top of this
for
a long time we've been you know i and
have you talked to cash i talked to cash
patel also
was on the national security council
head of counter and terrorism
i asked some point blank is there ever
any evidence
that white nationalism terrors the
biggest threat facing america
zero none this was the guy number one
national security council in charge of
counterterrorism
the secretary i'm sorry the chief of
staff for the secretary of defense
this guy was in there he has all the
intel
and also he'd be the first person to
complain about this fisa crap with uh
tucker
because he used faiza to actually go
after terrorists so he knows
this is why nothing we've been talking
about this i'm sorry i just finished
this thought we've been talking about
this for years basically
and now it's actually happening and we
still have to talk about it because not
everybody knows
i feel like we're beating uh we're
banging on a broken
drum no that doesn't work my mixed
metaphor
this is why i feel like there are two
great possibilities
of either an authoritarian takeover or a
civil war
because you look at what they're saying
about white supremacy in the far right
which is just fundamentally absurd and
not true
what they're saying about insurrection
it's the six-month anniversary and the
guy's like holding up his suit he's like
this is the suit i wore on that day
runs an article where they're like
journalists choking up in tears
see i i don't even want to go back in
the building six months later it is the
most insane garbage why
they don't want trump to come back they
need to say what are they saying now
a quote from trump about hitler i'm not
even going to repeat it
it's like the most absurd fake news
they're desperately trying to maintain
the narrative white supremacy
we're in a lowly year just you wait next
year 2023
2024 it is going to be insane i wouldn't
be surprised
if these capital police officers pop up
all over the country they arrest people
for these communications
they go on forums like you know
patriots.win which used to be the donald
and they'll say like who wants to go
commit this act and then people will say
something and then they'll arrest them
then they'll make some small stupid
tweet into a
massive indictment and the news will be
like extremists we're talking about
doing x y and z
the fbi will say who wants to do x y and
z and some guy will be like
sounds cool they'll arrest the guy and
say he was advocating for this deadness
he was planning it
we caught their communications we can't
release those to the public though
then they're gonna say trump is
inspiring this it's gonna get worse if
you vote for him
this is what you're going to get
black pills falling all over my head
i didn't say we were going to lose pills
it's going to be a struggle
i didn't say we're going to lose i said
i'm actually i'm actually confident
watching the media
fail now they'll try this stuff but look
how pathetic it is
when oliver darcy stands there with no
blinking yeah but nobody's watching them
the shift is happening their power is
dwindling that's true
they're going to try it the federal
government's going to try it you know
what they don't need the media anymore
you know why because they got your
four-year-old
that's right yeah you know who said that
who said what was that i got your
children oh no hitler
yeah it's a quote from hitler oh well
they have our children
yeah i was thinking you played
civilization i know you've played civ
before
you can go into a golden age we're in a
golden age right now that happens when a
bunch of great people get together
you can opt to use them to start a
golden age
last 20 30 40 years we are literally in
a golden age we're in a golden age
the internet internet video has allowed
us to unite all these great minds so we
formed a golden age now we're still
facing trauma and struggle but we're in
a golden age while we're doing it so we
have these bonuses
a golden age is basically a period of
great economic prosperity and no war
we've been in that for some time right
now you can be in one you could be in a
war and still be in a golden age
right the war in afghanistan is not a
real it's not like
no one's storming the u.s borders we
don't have germany bombing
america we are in a series of conflicts
but the general ideas perhaps you can
say right now we're not in a golden age
because of the conflicts we've seen with
china and russia and international
disputes and everything like that
but this country only for recently i
mean we're now entering the fourth
turning
for a long time we were just sure the
u.s goes out and blow stuff up yo there
was there was
10 years 1991 to 2001.
that was it that was a golden time
period
right and we didn't have any wars gold
war was well you could you know i
understand what you're saying but like
just impractical
you could be in a total war that's not
so this is a semantic misunderstanding
when i say no wars i'm talking about the
us actually fighting for its survival
ice but you could do that during a
golden age some countries thrive during
war in a golden age like ancient persia
was really in the game they're
extremely they can move now i'm not
talking about the game i'm talking about
the actual historical understanding of
gold
the metaphor is you can enter a golden
age during war
during a war time period and if you do
you're going to be much better equipped
to win the war right so what you're
basically saying is that we're all the
individual pieces of voltron
yes and we have forms and we need to
come together
it has it already happened in the golden
voltron is real now all right we have
the power of voltron we now but there's
aliens that are coming and we need to
fight these giant alien creatures i just
i just need you to take that sword off
the wall hold it in the air and yell i
have the power i do have the power you
are human i
and you and am skeletor and i will fail
you what do you say by the power of
grayskull
by the power of gray skull i have no
power you're going back into ancient
history
based on your birth year i grew up with
that dude that was me
saturday morning i'll be cringer i'll be
your cringer baby that was the cat that
turned into battle cat he wouldn't
wait cringer was the name cringer dude
dude i thought you were just saying like
i'm the cringy guy it's tasteful
it's timely thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to see the full show
come back to this channel
youtube.comcast irl
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments on
the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time